الحدث امريكي اما التداعيات فعابره لحدود
الولايات المتحده
هناك لقضايا دوليه راهنه تتقدمها الحرب في
اوكرانيا
عما قد تغيره نتائج انتخابات التجديد
النصفي للكونغرس من ملامح سياسه الامريكيه
تجاه ودعمها
من اول وهله ليس من تضاد تام لكن تطابق
غائب ايضا عن الرؤيتين الجمهوريه
والديمقراطيه تجاه المساله
حول الدعم الامريكي والمساعدات الماليه
وبشحنات الاسلحه لاوكرانيا عدا عما يترتب
عن الحرب من اعباء اقتصاديه
هنا يؤكد البيت الابيض الدعم الامريكيه
الثابته لاوكرانيا حتى وان فاز الحزب
الجمهوري في الانتخابات النصفيه
يعرب الجمهوريون عن هواجيسه حياله حجم
الانفاق اثار بعض تلك الهواجس كيفن مكارثي
زعيم الجمهوريين في مجلس النواب
رجل سيتولى رئاسه المجلس اذا فاز
الجمهوريون في الانتخابات النصفيه
على بياض اذا تولى حزمه السلطه
اوكرانيا في حال الفوز في الانتخابات
النصفيه
لاوكرانيا والذي يشمل مساعدات بقيمه 40
مليار دولار وقررت في مايو الماضي
حتى ان الرئيس بيدن طلب مبلغا اضافيا
يتجاوز 11 مليار دولار لا شيء مضمونا بعد
لذلك يدعو الرئيس الاوكراني الامريكيين
الى الحفاظ عما دعاها وحده ثابته حتى
ارساء السلام في بلاده ليس صدفه
في غمره انتخابات منتصف الولايه الحاسمه
في الولايات المتحده تدرك كيف ان سيطره
الجمهوريين على الكونغرس ستمنحهم سلطه منع
المساعدات عنها فهل يفعلونها لا يرجح ذلك
متابعون للمشهد الانتخابي الامريكي
لكنهم لا يستبعدون اقدامهم على ابطائي
تدفق الاسلحه والمساعدات الاقتصاديه
او الحد منها
عليهم قبل ذلك ان ينجح في الاخلال بمعادله
السيطره على الكونغرس وذاك امر بيد الناخب
الامريكي ومزاجه